all right let's go to richard in not so
normal illinois what's up richard how
are we doing man
i'm pretty good how are you doctor john
good i that was
about a fourth or fifth grade joke i
just made on
behalf of your city do people call it
not so normal all the time or not really
i there's a lot of stuff that people
call normal not so normal
oh my gosh like my work life right and
my marriage is not normal either
we could do this all day man what's up
so i
am a christian a father three and a
husband and i
struggle with anger issues and
yeah so that's my question how come how
can i deal with that
having two younger kids and then one
almost teenager uh and
if you have any questions please ask
yeah man that's
i love how simply you put that yet how
complex all the things you just rolled
out are
um who taught you to be angry
uh so i don't want to throw my dad under
the bus
but hey come on throw him he's not
listening richard
let's be real he's not listening i mean
i remember him being
quite angry a lot of times and having a
short fuse and i feel like i'm the same
way
and my son's five and i see i just see
that in him too
and my wife can get angry sometimes too
and we're just kind of navigating this
giant ocean we call life
as best we can okay so you picked it you
you your dad loved you probably a good
human being and he was an angry guy
and those aren't all mutually exclusive
we like to just dump people in these
buckets like terrible or awesome and
almost everybody's more complex than
that right so it's okay to call out your
dad and still love him
right and he doesn't need you to defend
him he's a grown man
so you learned a model of dealing with
challenges and frustrations that as you
mentioned that we just call life and you
learned to be angry
paint me a picture of what anger looks
like for you
um so i mean so i've been working a lot
in my church
with my small group leader and my my
church friends
on why i get angry about things or how
it goes but usually it's like
i guess i don't get my way and i watch
my kids make mistakes that i've made in
the past and
anger for me is getting frustrated
getting agitated very easily
and then if people raise their voice at
me i tend to raise my voice back
and that's that's anger for me so take
us all back to when you were seven
or maybe ten and your dad
lost his mind once just got raged out do
you have an incident that you remember
uh
yeah okay pretty pretty vividly too
um paint that picture for us when you're
a little one
well when when i was younger i remember
my mom and my dad fighting one time
and my dad picked up a chair and hit the
wall okay and so
my mom went upstairs and cried and i
didn't understand and i went to be with
her and she was just sad and i didn't
understand what was going on
okay so take us back transport us into
that little boy you saw that chair or
heard that chair smash against the wall
what's in that little boy what's that
little boy feeling
i was pretty scared i kind of went into
a different room and kind of hid
okay like show us where are you hiding
um so i hid in
the living room kind of behind the table
and then
after my mom went upstairs i quietly
went upstairs after my dad left the
house because he left the house after
that
okay so if if we were just to
like distill everything down between a
fight and a flight and a freeze you went
somewhere and got real still
right yeah you were a if you've seen
like the national geographic
with documentaries or whatever you were
the baby deer that curls up real tight
and just gets real still
my mom is dealing with whatever threat
right yep
um now when you think back on that you
happy that you're doing that to your kid
not at all man
because getting mad is okay getting
frustrated if you're not frustrated as a
parent of
a of a teen and young kids then you've
got some screws loose you probably
should go see a psychiatrist right
that's a frustrating enterprise
and then once you feel that frustration
once you feel that
even get mad everything after that's a
decision
and i hate to to simplify it so much
because i know people talk about being
trapped by it
or um controlled by it
and at this point in my life i don't buy
that anymore
a especially somebody who knows enough
to know that they're reaching out to
people
in accountability groups and are trying
and trying and trying so
the question most of us don't ever ask
is
why are you choosing to repeat this
cycle
so that your kid has to experience that
moment of
frozen terror in a side room
because they're scared of dad what is
what is choosing that res
that that outcome what does that get you
just more pain it doesn't help i know it
doesn't help
i just but you keep doing it you're
getting something from it what are you
getting from it
[Music]
i feel i feel like it's control
i seem i feel like i want to control
things really bad i want things to go my
way and i get
i've become a child that's angry when i
don't get my way
there you go man and so sometimes we
don't
care enough about ourselves when we're
first in
entering into i want to change my
behavior i want to change my life we
don't care enough about ourselves
and we don't have a model of people who
cared about us right if you the story
you just told
you were hiding in terror from your dad
and then your job was to go make sure
mom was okay
and that's not a seven-year-old's job on
either account
right yeah that's not your job as a
seven-year-old man
do you know what i did this morning and
i'm not making this up for
theater i'm just talking to my friend
richard this morning
i wrote a letter i'm i'm working with a
counselor i'm writing letters to my old
selves
and i wrote a letter to teenage john and
it ended with
go laugh and do stupid teenage things
you're going to be all right
and i love you and i'm letting these
kids off the hook that have been
protecting me for so long man and until
you let that seven-year-old
be a seven-year-old and not crouch in
terror in your living room
and then have to go take care of mom
because she's broken up
until you can let that kid go he's gonna
continue to run your life for you
and he's going to continue to respond
like a seven-year-old does which is
throwing things and pouting and you're
going to pass this along because your
kids are learning this model too
that's the thing i don't want to happen
i know i know you don't
and that's why you gotta let that little
kid go man
you gotta let that seven-year-old copy a
seven-year-old
and here's how that starts tonight you
write that little kid a letter
how old are your kids again my daughter
is one
my son's five and my my other daughter's
11. okay
so you're in it right you're exhausted
and you're going to all the
events in the evenings and you got a
five-year-old who's just running a muck
right so you're
and then you have a one-year-old that
just screams all the time and so
you are struggling your marriage is
probably strained right now
you're exhausted and you're trying to
wrap
all this up into a pretty little
christian dad and brother you're tired
okay so here's what i want you to do
number one i want you to prioritize
sleep
you've got to for the sake of your
family you have to
set a nighttime alarm and start going to
bed okay
number two i want you to get some time
and i want you to write that kid
a letter the one you just told us about
and i want you to write it from the
perspective of you as though you're
writing
to your seven-year-old self and let that
kid know
no kid should have to hide in the living
room because their dad is such a child
that he's smashing furniture against a
wall no kid should be that scared of his
dad
and no kid's job is to go make sure mom
is okay
because she's an adult she's a grown-up
and grown-ups should be able to work
together to solve problems and not smash
things and scare each other and hide
from one another
and then at the end of that letter i
want you to process all of the way that
kid's feeling and i want you to re-feel
that in your body and then i want you to
let that seven-year-old go play
and then from that moment i want you to
sit down with your wife it may not be
tonight it may be tomorrow or the next
day
and i want you to tell her i'm done
being angry
not done being mad not done being
frustrated right but i'm done being
angry and i'm done
responding like a child i want you to
give her permission to talk into your
life and then i want you to bring your
five and your 11 year old in
and let them know that you've been scary
and that you've been sad
and that you're not gonna be scared and
sad anymore
right and from that moment forward
you're going to start working on little
tiny things like when you feel yourself
get angry you're going to stop and say
i'm going to step outside and in your
head you're going to think because i'm a
grown-up
i'm not going to pass this on i'm going
gonna stare down this forest fire of
child of
family trauma and child trauma it stops
with me
and it's gonna be slow and it's gonna be
frustrating and you're gonna have idiots
in your life giving you all kinds of
stupid advice like
you just gotta get that anger out bro if
you try to get the anger out it's going
to re-groove your brain deeper and
become more and more and more of a
default setting
so you got to build new pathways and it
sucks building new pathways
but you have to because you got an 11
year old and a five-year-old and a
one-year-old and they can't carry this
on for you anymore
right yeah okay
do you have somebody in your life you
trust that's not a [ __ ]
that will walk along with you yeah i've
got two people
for sure and you trust them yeah
absolutely
and they don't give you stupid advice
nope like yeah bro you should be pissed
they they give you actual like
they chill out calm down no they tell me
that anger is sinning
and that i need to be careful because
i'll pass it on generationally
okay so anger is not a sin anger is not
bad
what you do with it is a sin yeah acting
like an idiot
is acting like an idiot right definitely
yeah
being angry is a po if you try to stamp
out anger dude you're trying to stamp
out
all anger means is that you care about
something
it points you in the direction of
something you care about and so when you
see your kid making a mistake you
care that he's not going to hurt like
you hurt
and then your reaction makes sure that
he hurts like you hurt right
so all anger is is pointing you in the
direction of something you care about
it's a good thing
it's wired into us right it's like you
just mentioned
it's our default setting it's what we do
afterwards
and that my friend is a choice and it's
going to be hard to change
but your kids are worth it and you are
worth it they are worth it yeah
hey hey you richard are worth it
okay you're worth being able to breathe
you're worth being able to sleep you're
worth not
feeling this shame all the time because
you
lost your temper on 11 year old or
you're
rage angry you're get pro tell me if i'm
wrong
you're able to control it sometimes but
you double down and you compress it in
your chest like a nuclear reactor
so everybody around you feels it but you
can walk through your house with a
little bit high and mighty because
you're not yelling or hitting anything
is that fair yeah yeah dude listen
that's almost worse not quite as bad as
smashing a chair but it's almost as
worse
because your kids feel that tension and
they backfill it with it must be their
fault
and you know what they do they spend the
rest of their life trying to take care
of mom
trend the rest of their life trying not
to make dad angry and that's not their
job
right so your job is to step outside on
the front porch and breathe
real deep
your job is to get a night's sleep your
job is to start every morning with what
you're grateful for
your job is to feel that anger and know
it's there and know
i love my kids bring it in guys
right your job is to not be immature
and to learn new tactics right
so don't let people tell you that
feeling angry is wrong it's not
smashing stuff in front of your kids is
right yep listen you're a brave guy
richard and i'm really really grateful
for your call
really grateful for your call and if you
can't tell this is the pot talking to
the kettle here and i've worked a long
long time on being angry
and i'm gonna tell you right now there
is healing on the other side of that
i laugh a lot more than i use two men
and i fall asleep most nights
not every night but most nights
and now i love going to little league
games and i used to not be able to go
because i would get all
right and your family
generationally right we talk here at
ramsey solutions about you know change
your family tree when it comes to money
you're going to change your family tree
when it comes to relationships and anger
and peace but i want to circle all the
way back
getting mad that's not always your
choice getting that lightning bolt of
anger
that's rarely your choice everything
after that
is a decision a choice and you my
brother are worth it
your wife is worth it and your three
kids are worth it